Hello everyone, welcome the first one
chrome of the shift I am alberto
joint in this video series
we'll talk about those integrated tools
in chrome that can give us support
in the development of our applications
web in particular will not be one
detailed presentation of each
single component of the beatles but more
what else a demonstration of how
these can help us in a
hypothetical development workflow for
any specific doubt you can
then I refer you to the
official documentation you can
find on the site of developer sti google
well let's see first
the application we'll be working on that
we will use to make ours
this is the chromology of the tools
here it is called shuriken and it is a small one
play that works so on the left
we have a bag that contains flowers
and if I can, however, this button
add a pair to the belt that is there
on the right I can then press the
button that is here and launch them with
suppose this fantastic animation
that this application has been there
requested by a customer is ours
hypothetical leader send us some gods
notifications telling us that they are there
changes or controls that
we should carry out on our own
application because maybe there is something
that doesn't work as it should
let's see then which is his first
message and tells us hi alberto i would
a couple of requests
you should add button
frequent est questions to the menu you should
make sure you like it to be red when there
almost over with the mouse
now you will see black and then you should
redo the style of the belt that
actually it doesn't really fit the
rest of the page then usually
we are used to working with the editor
of the source code on the one hand and the
browser on the other side making changes
in the editor maybe by passing the
code for a bill process is after a
some time see these on the
browser
this may not be exactly
immediate especially when
we didn't want to do simple things
prototypes in this case the ideal
just to make them brand browsers in
developer tools so let's go to
open them to open them we can go with
the menu went away tools developer tools
we can use the key combination
or in this case since we have to
edit html elements we can
select in this case the most
near where they will have to work click
with the right and do the inspect elements
doing so opens up developer tools
on the page the mans with those
actually selected this operation
there is very convenient in case for
example we are working
with a very large application too
maybe thousands of items save us
the effort to go and look for that one
specific element within the
facts then as you see here not only
we can display the html code but
we can also modify it doing this
there is enough to definitely click in
this case we take the parent to be able
element more than one we will have to create
we do and jackson to whom this
item turns into a box of
text that we can modify in the
which we can add new element
type out and see veiling was
added same speech applies to the css
below we have css of the element
selected right now here
we can click anywhere and
change the current selector however for
the request we have in this
moment we have to do an operation in
more specifically we were asked to
change the properties that come
applied for cover status ie
when there is the mouse over this
element here to change them we can
use this option here
allows to force a state
particular on an html element indeed
you see that at this moment the button
with is as if there were as if he had
always mouse over
furthermore, the relative has appeared
css code that is applied for
this was we can that of
modify it and see that it is applied
we can remove the forced state
we can see that this state comes
applied to all the elements because
was applied to the elements
inside the small delta nav
problem when I refresh
on the page
however, these changes are lost
chrome comes to our rescue in this
case because there is a very feature
interesting that is called workspace e
allows us to work on the browser and the
changes we make may come
automatically saved in the respective
fan source to do this let's go
in the options in we select workspace
and add the folder where we have
our application that we were giving
chrome permission to write to
this folder and if we go to the tab
sips school we can open the file
html for example is going to insert
directly here the new complaint
and restarts we can see that the
Population has been added itself
speech of course for the css file
around here
I open the css file here I can go to
change the format code to search
directly the property over can
add a new property
now as you can see, however, to save and me
this little yellow triangle has appeared here
above that indicates to me that the
file is not yet associated with a file
in my application folder
to make it be associated
I can click on it with the right do but
tour file system source which i
already suggests which file which then
matches and then you told me
restart them inspector doing so them
I open the file I can go back to
edit
in this case, if you don't, you don't like it
page also change ignition six
never been applied is saved in the file
source for the last change on
belt here I had already saved the
property to apply and you can see
that at the same time as the
comment
the properties are then applied to me
we have immediate feedback on the
changes we are doing other things than
we can do with html elements are
inspect the properties see the back
collins from the geom
or break points that are activated in the
time when there are changes to
a certain html element we can
see very kind is also if we
we select an html element and we have
the console or press this button
here to press heskey here if buttons
we use the special pain whine 0
we see that this is the element that we
we have selected we also have a
dollar one was the item and selected
previously and so on so if it
we want to do some operations
javascript
on these elements we can do them
directly this way without going
to look for them for example
document.getelementbyid or something
similar
in the next installment we will see how
within chrome we can emulate
other devices as we can for
example to test the responsibility
of our application
we will also begin to work on
javascript code
in particular the code that comes
executed following an operation that
we have carried out on the page you can
in other words the events of the dom